and now on to the man biden would lead
his doj
as attorney general merrick garland well
judge garland appeared before the senate
today where he classified the capital
rioters as domestic terrorists
but casually dismissed antifa
an attack on a
courthouse while in operation trying to
prevent
judges from actually deciding cases that
plainly is
domestic extremism
um um um uh domestic
uh terrorism um an attack simply on a
government property at night
or any other kind of circumstances is a
clear crime that's where i draw the line
joining me now is congressman devin
nunes ranking member on the house intel
committee congressman
this is truly frightening they're
they're not
i guess it depends on what time of day
you're attacking people or property to
be branded a domestic terrorist and
people thought he was
like going to be a judicial moderate if
he went on the supreme court
well that's the first thing that went
through my mind laura is thank god this
guy didn't make it onto the supreme
court
and i find it rather ironic that they
would this would be the first guy that
they pick
right out of the chute uh to be the guy
that becomes
the next uh head of the department of
justice with
so many things that are out there from
hunter biden to the durham
investigation to all of the problems and
the breakdown in the institutions that
we've had
and that answer it really gets to the
core problem that most of americans that
are watching your show right now believe
and that is that there's two
a two-tiered justice system everybody
wants all the rioters that broke into
the capital busted the windows they want
them busted
but they also want the same people that
created a new city and see or a new
country in seattle
attack courthouses burned down cities
they want them busted too
and that's really the problem we have in
this country it doesn't look like
garland's
going to make any improvements anytime
soon well this is how
judge garland described the january 6th
capital riot
what kind of forces are at work to
divide and destroy
the american dream there is a line from
oklahoma city
and there's another line to the battles
of the original justice department
against the
ku klux klan we are facing a more
dangerous period than we faced
in oklahoma city more dangerous than the
oakland
oklahoma city bombing we had so much
death and destruction i mean it was
on january 6 wasn't good but thank
goodness we didn't have
you know several dozen i'm more than 100
people
killed yes so look this is what's going
this is what's really going on out there
uh there's a narrative that's been in
the process and has been built over the
last several years
that republicans are domestic terrorists
racists all these bad things
and they need to use that because donald
trump's not there to
kick around anymore so they're going to
have to say that all of these people
that did this are
are racist and it is no surprise that
garland
is saying the same thing because he
knows that that's the narrative that has
to be
put forward and continued in order for
the democrats and the socialists left to
hang on to power in this country
well he also wants to become you know he
must have become our
nation's chief law enforcement officer
but somehow he hasn't thought anything
about the immigration laws
remarks look into that practice of using
asylum claims by drug cartels
to weaken border security
i had not known about this and i will
certainly look into this
problem do you believe that illegal
entry at america's border should remain
a crime
i just haven't thought about that
question hasn't thought about it
that's a little hard to believe i think
well laura
it's not hard to believe because he has
thought about it he knows exactly
why he can't answer these questions he
knows the right answer
at one point this guy was probably a
moderate you know 20 years ago or
something
but clearly now to be part of the
socialist left to
enter into the biden harris
administration
you have to hold the line on the
narratives as the narratives are
constructed so
i i've watched a little bit of this
today and i've seen some clips i mean he
he answered i don't know i don't know
about that i don't know how many times
so but he does know he has to know he's
a guy who's been around politics
uh for decades and he's been in the
judicial branch he absolutely knows
answers to the questions and he knows
damn well that people that invade into a
courthouse or
cross over the border illegally are
breaking the law now
there's just certain boxes you have to
check in order to be a democrat today
and one of them is you have to say the
country's systemically racist
and you have to say that illegal
immigration is not a crime i mean he
just went through that whole checklist
and john kennedy just
fellate him on the issue of systemic
racism it was unbelievable congressman
great to have you on tonight thank you